if you're a fan of the content that i
produce
then you're probably not a fan of
corporate press mainstream media
because i know i'm not and i rag on them
all the time so i can only assume if you
watch the videos of me ragging on
corporate press mainstream media
these big tech conglomerates and the big
media conglomerates
i can only assume you probably don't
like them either well recently
a whistleblower stepped forward and came
to project veritas revealing
censorship at fox 26 that whistleblower
is here with us today
ivory you want to introduce yourself hey
guys my name is ivory hecker and i
am a tim fan so i'm honored to be out
here
yeah so uh this is a funny story
you uh you were just in new york yeah
and uh how did you how did can you can
you
tell everybody how you ended up oh yeah
so yeah so i was in new york
uh so many people have been wanting to
interview me and so i've
been very busy with that as well as well
as trying to edit content
and get this true story out there
there's so much to tell
um and then i get a note from tim
um saying would you
is there any way that you could come on
the show in person tonight and i know we
have
like five hours five hours yeah and i
was like oh my gosh
i was like okay i'm looking into a
helicopter or a plane or something
and he was like please film yourself
going onto a helicopter and i was like
look that's how awesome your show is
oh thanks man i'm gonna find ourselves a
helicopter and get on
right yeah well you made it and this is
gonna be awesome so we're gonna talk all
about corruption and media there's a
bunch of stories i mean right now
joe biden has been he was at the g7
summit he was with putin and a lot of
people even you know many people on the
left and the right are pointing out
the american journalists are screaming
at putin and not asking any of these
questions to joe biden
we don't have a fair and honest media in
this country anymore so i'm glad you're
here and we're going to talk about your
story
of course i have a somewhat similar
story i didn't blow the whistle and come
out and you know do some big expose but
i've
certainly experienced a lot of what
you've you've talked about so we'll get
in all that of course we got luke
you guys are causing some serious
microaggressions against the mainstream
media
and that's totally not cool mika
brzezinski of msnbc who previously said
it's her job to control
exactly what people think probably
doesn't appreciate it so
yeah welcome i am your humble t-shirt
vendor and if you like the t-shirts i
wear you could get them at
thebestpoliticos.com including the one
that i wear now and
i might be live tweeting on luke we are
changed thanks for having me
live tweeting well hey i'm ian crossland
what's up everybody ivory i'm glad
you're here glad to hear i want to hear
about this i've heard a little bit about
it so
i'm glad to hear from about it from your
perspective i'm so honored to be here
and i am so excited to have ivory as
well i always love having ladies on the
show especially ladies with big
um what do they call them lady cojones
yes i love the way
she unpacked this for the the audience
at large i think it's great i'm excited
we're gonna learn a lot about the inner
workings of the media
and why we experience lies and
manipulation of course i've got personal
experience but we've got a big story
right now so
we'll get into that before we do head
over to timcast.com
sign up to become a member by clicking
that members only button
and you'll get access to the exclusive
members only area but you may notice
there's
other posts there i'll be completing
this they're not supposed to be there uh
many of these posts are for some reason
appearing we knew we knew we were gonna
have a formatting issue but i wanted to
launch the newsroom sap
so we've had cassandra fairbanks sign on
as our new editor-in-chief and she's
been writing articles
we're doing phone calls with a bunch of
journalists we're gonna be moving people
into the area and that's because
your memberships allow us to hire real
journalists
many people who are excited to have the
ability to write
real news without political agenda i'm
not going to tell people what politics
they have i'm going to say just write
the facts
we're going to get a fact checker and
they're going to fact check because
we're going to double up make sure
real news is coming out and that's
because you guys remember so i think
in in in the the genre that we're about
to enter
media criticism it's entirely perfect so
we have a bunch of amazing articles that
just went up and we will have a bonus
members only segment coming up
around 11 or so p.m after the show four
members of the website
and then the full site should be
launching in well
i can say two or three weeks but there's
going to be qa there's going to be
testing and stuff so
we'll see but hopefully within the next
month or so we will have a fully
functioning news site
with hopefully i'm thinking five people
working on the news team to start
so that's because you guys are members
don't forget to smash
that like button right now subscribe to
this channel hit that notification bell
share the show with your friends if you
think the stories that we're gonna we're
gonna hear right now about corruption
and media if you think this stuff is
very important
and people need to know about it maybe
they don't believe you when you tell
them the media is not telling you the
truth
this is the video this is the show share
this with them
take the url if you think we deserve
better ratings at cnn
please share the video it really does
help let's get into the first story
we got this link from project veritas
fox 26 houston tv reporter ivory hecker
goes public
i don't need to read it every sitting
right here so let's just start from the
beginning
what uh what happened well
weird stuff started to happen late last
summer
they they the first thing that just
really stunned me was when fox 26 sent
me to
cover covet treatment at a hospital they
didn't like what the doctor said
and then they went ahead and punished me
for allowing his son uh his sound bite
to reach
people's eardrums so so you you
you just asked the doctor some questions
and yeah you got in trouble for what the
person they wanted you to interview said
a medical professional
yeah so um yeah so this was this was two
weeks after dr stella emanuel
spoke in dc saying saying what she said
about hydroxychlorquin
and then i i was sent two weeks later to
talk to a doctor who was treating covet
patient he had actually teamed up with
the
army medical team from the department of
defense
they were all treating covet patients
and
the interview was very dull the army
wouldn't tell me anything
uh i knew that the audience was still
buzzing about
hydroxychloroquine after all of that
crazy news about
still emanuel the mass censorship across
social media that we saw after that
people still people had i think people
had lost more trust than ever
in in media when they saw this strange
blackout
where every hydroxychlorquin post was
being deleted um
still yeah so so even even we have to be
careful otherwise youtube would take the
whole show down
right yeah so sorry i'm saying the h
word i hope i hope your show survives
look i changed it if it gets deleted it
does yeah
if youtube pulls that and it's that
creepy because we're talking about
censorship in in the media
yeah i mean that's that's the level of
insanity we're dealing with right now
yeah
and we're not telling people what to do
we're not medical professionals so we
want to clarify that
and we're just talking about the facts
of the story which are very important
you talked to a medical professional in
the field
dealing with real life situations and
and could you
could you expand on on on his kind of
take
what was what was like why why did this
happen here
this all that happened doll interview
with the army they won't tell me a thing
i know people are buzzing about
hydroxychloroquine so i say
final question of the whole interview i
say by the way did you do you guys
do you guys use hydroxycorquin and then
he said actually
we we have used it and we've had great
success
i know it's very controversial but we
throw the whole kitchen sink at them we
treat we treat them with a lot of they
have a whole recipe of treatments for
covered patients
and uh so i i actually added that as the
final soundbite in my
tv package and by the way guys i just i
the story i'm telling you i literally
just
uploaded uh youtube if you check my
social media
i uploaded my boss's own words on this
so you can go
check what my boss has said about this
uh after after
the show youtube.com ivory hecker i
believe
or yeah i mean just search ivory hacker
i guess i don't know if it's
sometimes that doesn't work yeah i guess
yeah and maybe it doesn't work
anyway uh if you go to my instagram
real.ivory i just uploaded it there
anyway so uh so the bosses
the boss i added that is the last
soundbite of the package oh by the way
he he is using
this this hospital is implementing the
controversial drug
uh and i and i called it controversial i
just left it at that and uh
my minutes before era my bosses were
like get rid of that sound by
we do not want that in our newscast and
i was like okay
well why is that um they said it well
you didn't
include the context of other drugs
they're using i was like oh okay okay so
i got rid of it from the
tv news it didn't air in the tv news i
uploaded that soundbite to facebook with
the caption having all the drugs he uses
to treat covet so his whole
his whole recipe is on there and the
bosses
flipped out they flipped out they said
that i
uh was not following their instruction i
did exactly what they told me to do
right
wow so anyway they went so far
as to uh they actually shut down my
social media said
they said you're not allowed to post
anything until we say so
and then so i was in like a week-long
blackout
and then they said okay you can post on
social media but only
things that we approve which is safe
news wow
and but then uh they but they instituted
basically a permanent social uh social
uh a permanent ban on coverage of
coveted drug treatments so i was no
longer allowed to
cover covet drug treatments because i
could not comprehend the narrative the
narrative
the president was talking about this
right and here's the thing
this i'm i'm adding zero commentary zero
opinion
opinion to this just here's his sound
bite this is what he said
yeah yahoo news had a story about you
know
hcq and they had a story titled drug
endorsed by trump
no more effective than placebo at
warding off coronavirus studies suggest
a couple days ago they had another
article by yahoo news i'm not saying
this yahoo news is saying this
studies shows hydroxychloroquine and
zinc treatments increased coronavirus
survival rate by almost
three times that's yahoo news but to be
fair i mean it's a year apart yeah
so there was some there were some
studies a lot that would that have been
retracted
and i think the i think here's the
fascinating thing though
that doctor i interviewed he was adding
the zinc with the hydroxyl
apparently people are saying that it
works more effectively if there's zinc
mixed with it and there's other previous
studies without zinc
uh and and that's why dr chris martinson
of peak prosperity was talking about how
there was a debunked study that that
was personally not adding up to the
science that that he questioned that
came out about hydroxychloride so let's
let's just say this right now do not
take any advice
like you've seriously got to talk to a
doctor you do not get it from us
just because there's some yahoo stories
that say one thing or another doesn't
mean you should do anything
you should talk to a doctor and take
your doctor's advice i think the biggest
thing
i think one of the things youtube is
concerned about one of the things is
that you get these
stories about this lady eating fish food
or whatever and they don't want to get
smeared in the media
having supported shows that have
promoted or talked about it at all so
we're not
we i want to be very clear our focus is
on the media's response to this
exactly you go and talk to a doctor
before you do anything so
looking at the comparison of those two
studies almost a year apart
it's just it's more of a confirmation
that we need to keep the conversation
going out in the public
stop shutting down conversation about
this because
we could have we could have maybe
connected more dots on this a lot
earlier
well i will i will add that that study
that's come out is not peer-reviewed
and it's it's a it's a preliminary
research study that is not to be used
for guidelines according to it's like
the first paragraph in the study says do
not use this for clinic for you know in
clinical use
it is not peer-reviewed so i think this
is one of the things that we have to be
careful about and
for whatever reason youtube freaks out
now i will say
the creepier aspect of it is you can't
even you can't even ask a doctor
right right it was a doctor who was
doing but here's
here's one thing that just stopped me in
my tracks
a couple of weeks ago i was i was
thinking back to that doctor and
thinking over this
this crazy journey these past like 10
months or whatever it's been
and i googled him and i came across
some something that said that his
death rate was dramatically lower in his
hospital than other hospitals and i was
like what and i looked into this further
and i actually made calls myself and and
collected
raw data and came to find
that he has dramatically lower death
rates
at his hospital compared to other
hospitals across
the county the nation and the world
this is a major story and i think this
is why youtube has had
the hammer on it so effectively because
you know there's a lot of implications
here i don't want to jump to conclusions
i'm not going to jump to conclusions
but people should do their own research
do their own homework the medical
studies are out there you could read
them yourselves
some are debunked but but the
conversations that are being had
are are having to be had outside of big
social media companies and that's sad
and also outside of corporate news
outlets as well i will i will add there
is a really creepy
like i don't i don't you describe it but
the there's the left the establishment
left has their creepy blue and on world
view where rachel maddow screams russia
for years and they'll just believe it
and then you do have you know q anon
people and people who just outright
believe certain things
and this is the challenge um people
going online and just reading
whatever and assuming it's true that's
why i'm like
look a lot we've mentioned this before
i've had people say that they don't
trust their own doctor and i'm like if
you don't trust
your own local doctor like who do you
trust like what do you do you know what
i mean like
what's your response to go ask your
neighbor agatha or something like i'm
sorry i couldn't do that
i have to talk to a doctor maybe get a
second opinion you should have a
relationship with them you should get
some of the scientific studies send them
to your medical professional and have an
honest real discussion with them because
if you can't trust your doctor
you're at the wrong doctor you should be
having real honest conversations but i
gotta stress this point
i turn on the tv every day and you'll
see like some woman with blonde pigtails
prancing through the fields and it'll be
like she's happy because she takes
flobodon is flabbo done right for you
and i'm like they just promote they
don't even tell me what the drug does
yeah i remember seeing a commercial i'm
not gonna name the drug they'll come
after me these people are litigious
but it was like sure i'll keep it vague
and it was asking if this drug is right
for you and i'm just like you didn't
even tell me what it does
yeah so it's like some old man's going
to call and he's going to be like i saw
a commercial is it right for me and
they're like sir this is for pregnant
women
well the commercial didn't tell me that
but but these commercials that youtube
is probably taking ad money from oh tv
news is definitely taking ad money from
that and any tv news viewer knows that
the commercial breaks are full of drug
companies okay
tv news is heavily funded by drug
companies
and does that compromise the news cast
when the coverage turn comes to drugs i
don't know but
but here's the thing guys so i when i
found out those those
death rates at the hospital it really uh
you know made me stop in my tracks and
say let me circle back to that story
they banned me from last year
so that's what i've been digging on the
past few weeks i'm going to release an
independent report on this
in in the coming days uh unveiling uh
you know really digging deep into the
banned information about about what's
really happening in these hospitals what
what this guy's doing and he
he's not just just using one he actually
faced hydroxychloroquine out because
he got too much pressure on him the
pressure was intense
he was using a recipe of almost almost
10 different items that were really key
he says it's a very interesting story
i'm going to talk to
quite a few people for this report and i
hope you guys enjoy it i know some
medical doctors too that i could connect
you with uh and also
another thing i wanted to add i love
hearing the side effects for those
commercials
yeah when they like like it's a jillion
yeah yeah and it's like
what the hell that's
going back to like the corporate side of
this they i guess what they were saying
was that
in in this video that came out that uh
when you the video you got for project
veritas
you had one higher up saying that
about bitcoin that certain you know
ethnic minorities wouldn't be interested
in stories so they don't report it
and so i'm wondering in this regard if
what what is the reason why a corporate
executive would say
don't tell this story it sounds like the
answer is they want to make money
right yeah i really i really
am not entirely sure what the motive was
at the top
i think i think fox at this time and i'm
talking fox corp
they they feel such a target on their
back for
having the name fox and they are
really you're really watching fox start
to crumble to that pressure is what's
happening is
they're starting to be so careful
and if they see other media censoring
something out they join that team and
say
we'll be safer yeah that's fine oh yeah
yeah so uh what i found interesting in
the in the the video
that you did or that you released was
when
the that one woman says you know she
passed on a story about bitcoin because
the 5 pm
hour is like largely you know black
people who wouldn't be interested in
this story
things like that and you mentioned that
they were really like targeting
demographics and trying to figure out
what news would cater to them
yes could you can you explain that to us
oh yeah it's in
in news it's like everything's broken
down into these little demographics
and actually the it's like a large
amount of the behind-the-scenes
conversation in news is about racial
groups
well what's this racial group doing
what's that racial group doing and how
will this racial group respond
to this news or whatever and it it's
it's crazy it's uh it's it's all through
race colored
lenses opposite of what mlk had in mind
by the way but
uh so yeah they they she just made an
assumption that that uh if you're poor
and black you don't care about
bitcoin maybe it's because they haven't
been told about bitcoin because
these news outlets just say they
wouldn't care anyway
they make an assumption about a person
based on their race when they could be
wrong
maybe if you gave information to people
an opportunity to understand they might
actually care about it
right and if you look at one technology
that has enriched people has helped
people has taken people out of poverty
and
given them some wealth what technology
recently has allowed people to do that
cryptocurrencies and bitcoin they have
helped so many developing countries
third world countries there have been so
many charity efforts there have been so
many amazing things happening in the
bitcoin cryptocurrency space that help
people
that it's just it's just kind of crazy
to see someone's perception
controlling uh you know the reporting on
something that is so crucially important
uh like bitcoin
it feels to me like there's
i guess it's a hive mind it's the
collective i refer to group
think yeah right so there is this major
media hive and if you step out of line
they all point at you in the same
direction and they fire their
figurative you know uh lasers at you
all of a sudden now you're getting the
heat from every single media outlet
every single activist organization
and then everyone gets scared it'll come
for them so they shut off working with
you you get canceled
i wonder if that's what we're seeing
with like you mentioned the pressure at
these news stations
yeah fox doesn't want to get canceled by
by
being being said to be touting
a drug that is said to not work so
they're just gonna
they're they're gonna ban coverage of
the jug to protect themselves
i actually have experience with this so
when i worked for
fusion which was the abc news univision
joint venture
i was talking to the president of the
company and he told me
you know our job here is to side with
the audience that's what he called it
what it basically meant was we make news
you know content that caters to a group
of people that is
looking for that confirmation bias i
asked him i was like so
are you saying to me that if there is a
factual news story
but it would be offensive to our
audience we don't report it and he said
i think that's fair yes that i think
summarizes it
that is the state of the american media
that happened to me almost six years ago
okay so this is yours this is your story
yeah yeah yeah
oh my gosh i was i was basically trying
to quit for the past 10 months but i had
this crazy rigid fox contract
that's exactly what happened to me
what's your okay i had a two-year
contract with fusion
and after about a year i'll i'll i'll
start from the beginning so
you know i worked at vice i got
contacted by this recruitment company
they said here's what we want to do we
basically we love what you've done with
vice news because i was that was the
founding member i was the first person
they hired and
really shaped a lot of it they said we
want you to do that exact same thing
here with new technology new methodology
and and i was like that's fantastic went
and talked they gave me some numbers i
said this is fantastic i'm gonna have
a budget i'm gonna have a team i'm gonna
be making great money and we're gonna
launch something really incredible
within about six months or so the
company went from we want to be
edgy and youthful too we are completely
woke in every way
and we outright hate white people i'm
not kidding the editor-in-chief changed
his twitter banner to say down with
whiteness
and it was a black fist like revolution
fest
and so that to me was like okay i
i just go on the ground and i tell
people what's happening
i'm not here to claim a race as bad or
to push ideology and so i started uh
having these conversations where i'd be
just i just say like hey i'm not
comfortable with the content
shift and eventually it became more
golden handcuffs for me
they didn't want this kind of content
anymore they wanted activist
progressive and this is how the
conversation came about
one of the first was i said look if if
uh you know
was when i was i go to his office and i
said i see what's going on at this
company
i don't agree with your ideology it
doesn't fit
like my style of reporting i just want
to do on the ground
you know documentaries i went to a
weapons expo in in brazil
we went we looked at guns and missiles
and there were generals walking around
and stuff
nothing overtly ideological and so
when i when i when i come back and i see
what they're doing with all the content
i'm like
this stuff is laughable i mean like
you're dumping what hundreds of millions
of dollars into being
to make an activist blog but people do
this work for free you don't need to
start a news room to make an activist
blog go
start a non-profit do you want to
actually do news and want to make a
successful company this isn't going to
work
that's where that conversation comes
from where he says look we're just here
to side with the audience a nice
and then i said what audience is that
and he says look young people are
progressive this is the thing that they
want
and i said i don't think it's about what
they want i think it's about
giving fair and honest information so
that they can understand what's
happening in the world
and then he said look you know we're
here to just side with the audience
that's when i said
does that mean if there's a factual news
story that would be offensive to them we
wouldn't report he said yes i think
that's fair
i had a meeting with them in i think
this was in california because
that we were based in miami and i sat
down with them after about
a year or so into the contract and i
said if this is the way
things are going to go clearly i
shouldn't be here
so how about we just end it now and you
guys sever my contract
but they didn't want to do that i think
they were worried that i was one of
their high profile hires they called it
the expendables they hired a bunch of
prominent personalities from across new
york media they were like what would
happen if the news comes out tim will
breaks contract and quits they don't
want to deal with the bad pr
so he was like oh i see what you're
saying i'm really sorry
we'll uh we'll figure it out the
president outright told me that the
company was racist
like straight up to the company was
racist and it was and it was you know
there were issues
and so he said we'll talk about it later
well what ended up happening later was i
got a phone call and
i thought this was it i got an email
they're like we need to have a
conversation with you and i was like
finally it's been a few months
now they're going to end my contract
early and i can be be rid of this this
you know this company
no i get a phone call thinking the guy's
going to say we've you know considered
what you've talked about and we're going
to let you go instead he said
i just wanted to let you know um we have
a very serious uh
matter to discuss with you and and and i
think um i'd
rather just tell you in person and i was
like wonderful he goes yes uh we're
gonna be depositing a very large bonus
should be around forty thousand dollars
into your bank account and we don't want
you to be alarmed by the number
and i went what yeah yeah everyone's
getting a bonus and i started laughing
and i was like is this a joke i i don't
even know why i got a bonus
i was not part of whatever the structure
is they were trying to build and then i
look at my bank and i'm like
okay and then i just waited i suppose
and
had more and more the same conversations
they didn't want this kind of coverage
anymore
i can understand it when they want to
start the company they wanted to make
vice
after they changed their
course they realized they had me under a
contract and they didn't want to look
bad
so then come august of 2016 the same
thing happens we should call
and i'm like here it is my contract is
up thank you for everything you've done
for the company at this time we will not
be renewing your contract and i said
thank you and have a nice day
and that was it that was done and that's
when i started my own youtube thing
that's corruption yeah they their their
goal was not to provide information to
people to help them better their lives
their explicit goal their expressed goal
was to give
confirmation bias to people now i know
the left will look at my content and say
tim you read on democrats all day and
night blah blah
yeah that's a fair point i mean i
personally as a pundit and commentator
do
i have my biases i rag on the
republicans in a different way and not
nearly as much as i do the democrats
but we're gonna do something very very
different with our newsroom we're gonna
get an independent fact checker
two or three and they're gonna be in a
different office outside of our news
checking the articles we write
because we're going to do it properly
that's
so you know when i heard your story i
was like i've i've experienced a lot of
the similar similar things right when
when you had that video
of the woman saying the audience
wouldn't care about that you know why
should we report on bitcoin the
auditor's not going to care about that
i'm like i know exactly what they're
saying
and then when i thought it was
interesting too because there's two
sides to this
you mentioned that they're just
interested in the executive's opinion
and that's also bad we don't want
newsrooms
where you have one executive saying i
just want propaganda for my world view
and we also don't want a newsroom that
says just feed the the peasants whatever
confirmation bias you can give them
you want an eclectic group of real
reporters
with varying world views seeking out the
truth seeking out information
and disseminating it and that means
often you'll have something that will be
offensive to republicans offensive to
democrats young people hated old people
will hate it
and then there will be a lot of things
that people appreciate a big expose in a
corporate malfeasance but when you have
when you have a ceo you know what
happens when you have an executive
sticking his finger in the editorial
i've seen it they say oh is that what's
that story
there's a large soda company that's
doing something wrong
well they sponsor us so we're not going
to report on that and then they they
stick their finger into the news
reporting and they shut down very
important stories about corporate
malfeasance
in the inverse you have people saying
just tell the audience whatever they
want to hear and you can't have either
that it's got to be
about seeking truth and providing
information whether people like it or
not
exactly in fact there's another big
story that i
that i have been trying to get out to
viewers
there's a few things that i need to do
to to verify what's going on
and get it out there and and i presented
this story to my bosses
and a couple months ago i'm not going to
go into detail because i'm still working
on this story but
uh i told my bosses there's two people i
need to track down on the ground
i need to just run into them and have a
mic
and hey so what's going on you know and
they
said absolutely not they were just like
oh what you're crazy
we would never just confront someone
like that it was like what
like that that is journalism getting
getting that person this is this is a
potentially very dark story if this if
what happened is true
that is dirty yeah luke's luke's got
experience with running up to people and
i mean that's what it's real journalism
going up to people doorstepping them
asking them a question that's not
scripted everything we see
on the mainstream media right now is
carefully written
carefully scripted joe biden gets
pre-approved questions in front of him
that he has cue cards for that he
answers there is i can tell you the only
reason
i can verify that yeah yeah and then i
remember being at
a lecture for condoleezza rice and she
was she was doing a q a allegedly from
the general public
and she was asked questions and then i
remembered later that day
watching the jon stewart show because
this was a few years ago the same
exact questions that allegedly came from
the audience
was what jon stewart was asking
condoleezza rice in this
you know pre-scripted interview that she
knew all the right talking points to
sell her book
she probably sent him the questions and
said this is how i realized
and this is this is their book this is
this is all a big illusion and i
remember
being there right before you went from
vice to to
to fusion and disney i remember i was
like timmy no don't join the dark side
don't do it wasn't vice bad enough
i was like i already had enough
conflicts with vice there was some drama
between me and them
we even shot a full skit about us
testing less lethal weapons on each
other
we sat down got tear gassed together oh
we did a whole segment
and then and then we couldn't even no
one even saw that video footage well
that's different that's
that that was more like a major
corporation
that wanted to be cool exactly and
didn't understand
anything i told them and what we did was
really i was like
we want to go to a secure location where
we can we can test out these police
tactics
in an open field they brought us to a
parking lot at mcdonald's and i'm like
we we can't we can't do this here like
this you can't release tear gas in a
parking lot like what are you doing yeah
the feds showed up it's a long crazy
story
uh exciting yeah it was wild but um
what what you experienced happening to
you the kind of golden handcuffs
happened to a lot of people whether it's
philip donahue whether it's jesse van
tura
there's a lot of people reporting how
they get bought out by big companies
and all they have to do is not do
anything guys
yeah when you said golden handcuffs i
was like what a concept that
i i almost felt in some ways like that's
been something that's been happening to
me
the more i push back internally i i mean
i started
i started aggressively pushing back
against my bosses
on these things like i lost all fear of
confrontation with my bosses when i saw
the depths to which they stooped late
last summer i was like okay
i don't want to be a part of this
company anyway so i'm not going to
tiptoe around my bosses
and i started to i started to call them
out every chance i got every time they
did something sketchy i would call them
out
and what started to happen is i i
started to
like get any day off that i wanted i got
like two weeks off over christmas and
and new year's and i i i never have to
work weekends
uh it's just so i i don't i don't want
to ask you to answer this about you
personally
but um would you say that these local
newsrooms in general on average
pay well uh in
in houston it's uh it's a decent amount
i i mean it's not
like relative but it's it's not it's not
low it's
it's probably more than most people make
right that's what i'm wondering you know
for like somebody who lives in the
houston area maybe they're a a trades
they work a trade of some sort or maybe
they have you know they drive uber or
they maybe work at a walmart or
something
yeah we're definitely making more than
those people yeah this is what i find
really fascinating about the whole thing
is it's almost like
the whole system relies on you just
recognizing
that you are a privileged elite and you
don't want to leave the club
right i walk into vice when i first
started there
a lot of those people got paid really
poorly let's be honest like vice didn't
pay out that well they were notorious
for it
but there are many news outlets uh um
in new york i shouldn't even call them
news outlets they pay an insane amount
of money
60 grand to write listicles about you
know like different hamsters they saw on
the internet
it's like why are they getting paid so
much per year when the guy who cleans
the toilets
gets paid a third of that or or half
that why is it that the guy has to wait
around in the sewer is getting paid less
than the person
who's fresh out of college with no
experience writing trash
for the internet i think it's because
control of information is extremely
important so they want people to look
around and say
i don't want to be a garbage man they
they do like i mean this is what we hear
when we grow up right
they they say oh if you don't go to
school you could end up being a garbage
man
my dad never told me that he said
garbage man might be very happy he
probably makes great money better than
the guy at mcdonald's
mcdonald's guy's probably happy too who
knows some people probably aren't happy
happiness has nothing to do with that
so i found that you know interesting but
i think about how we we teach our kids
this
you don't want to be a burger flipper
you don't want to be a garbage man then
all of a sudden these people
they get this privileged access where
they're getting paid a bunch of money to
do basically
nothing it's not real work i'm talking
about new york blogs i'm not talking
about actual journalism
they don't want to leave that club they
don't want to step out of line there's
money to be made
so golden handcuffs works in a couple
different ways when you get a contract
they tell you hey we're not going to use
this story every single time you you get
one no we're not interested no we're not
interested have a nice day
then they just basically you end up
sitting in the corner of an office
getting paid decently
doing nothing the other kind of golden
handcuffs is more of the peer pressure
kind where it's like well you're not a
bigot are you
you agree with us that is what is
prolific in tv news
they they the wokeness the the the oh
you're not
you're not it's basically you're you're
not right wing at all are you
right that was a slightly right-leaning
pitch
there you pitched a story that uh
well you know what are your views you
know and everyone in
in news is terrified
to ever be thought to possibly
lean to the right you have to be leaning
to the left which is which is
so sad you shouldn't be leaning anywhere
you should be just
looking for the facts period yeah uh but
in in
in looking for what the audience has
questions about
we as journalists have more access to
the audience than ever before
we get to just look at our own social
media comments and see what the audience
cares about what they want answer
answers to and what i saw at fox is an
audience
screaming in the comment section
so frustrated the fox 26 viewers were so
disgusted with box ma6 and their
questions were what i
started pitching in the meetings in our
morning editorial meetings
and and i watched the pitches get shot
down shot down shot down but isn't it
weird then when you had that supervisor
say
that you know the 5 pm slot doesn't make
sense to talk about bitcoin because
the people who watched aren't interested
in it if the if
it's weird that they're they're kind of
doing both things like oh we know
our audience won't like the story we
won't do it meanwhile you actually have
people on your social media saying hey
we'd like to know more about this
we're not going to do that either right
seems more like it was an excuse for
them to pick and choose what stories
they want to promote
of course they didn't want to promote
bitcoin bitcoin gives regular people a
way out
so i'll i'll put it this way i'm not a
financial advisor
do not take this to be financial advice
and i'm going to tell you about my
opinions
if you put money in a savings account
when i put money
in a savings account inflation devalues
my currency
the my ability to buy things diminishes
over time because the way the federal
reserve prints money
when i put my money in bitcoin the value
of the bitcoin
went up and the va my purchasing power
actually increased
teaching poor people that they could
find a way out
i have to imagine a lot of elites and
rich people don't like the idea that
poor people can escape the system
they've created
yeah it's it's incredible you know i
just discovered bitcoin in november
and made some nice money nice money from
it november
yeah that was a good time yeah so it was
at around 13 000 or so and then uh and
now it's at forty
and all the naysayers and all these
outlets keep wanna keep one and say oh
no it was at 65 and now it fell so it's
bad and i'm just like
yeah look man if someone gave me a
dollar right now
would i put it in a savings account or
would i put it i put in bitcoin
because because me personally my
personal opinion not financial advice
is that that dollar is gonna retain its
value or increase i put in the savings
account it's gonna it's gonna inflate
and become worthless
but tim poor people getting rich is a
big no no we can't allow that we can
allow people to have their own
individual economic freedom and
sovereignty through cryptocurrencies
that's it yeah it's not about getting
rich it's about if i work
the value of my labor is retained
exactly and i totally agree with you and
that's why we have seen such concerted
efforts throughout the years i've been
hearing them ever since
bitcoin went from 400 to 200 ever since
it went from 2000 to 800
it's always bitcoin is over it's
collapsing it's never going to become a
thing
it's horrible for the world it's it's
causing pollution
meanwhile look at the carbon created by
the military industrial complex look at
the carbon created by gold mining
and it's way higher than bitcoin i i
previously just put out a chart on my
twitter account showing
the exact amount of co2 caused by all
these other alternatives and bitcoin is
all the way down there very low but
yet again elizabeth warren is the one
campaigning a huge
war against bitcoin trying to of course
control it regulate it and of course
make sure that people can't
enrich themselves some way or keep their
money some way through the larger
financial crimes that are happening well
against
the public right now let's go back to
that thing you were mentioning let's see
i think i have this pull this up
somewhere yes where we have it from
gravy and uh
great grabian news micah brzezinski said
this is february 22nd 2017. our job is
to control
exactly what people think yeah they do
yeah
and and and what were they telling
everybody in 2008 just before the big
crash
everything's fine the economy is great
invest in the stock market go buy a
house go get yourself a loan
everything's hunky-dory and they knew
yeah what were they telling us in 2003
there's wmds weapons of mass destruction
they're working
osama bin laden is working with iraq
they're making
yellow cake and they're creating wet and
they're and they're creating little
small nuclear devices that will be
blowing up in new york city uh and then
we could go on we could we could go on
to
2001 when they told everyone the air was
safe to breathe down
at ground zero when it wasn't it was
filled with asbestos but the mainstream
media knowingly
that previously just a few months ago
was talking about the asbestos in the
twin towers
being white elephants just months ago
the new york times before 9 11 was
talking about that
they were now reporting the air is
completely safe to breathe
at ground zero even though it was filled
with asbestos and then the criminality
there
and you know i be i'm sure it's because
the local
law enforcement said that or the alert
no no
chris christie todd whitman announced
that after the epa got their results
fudged the data the data went through
condoleezza rice conde lisa rice edited
out that it was unsafe
that it was toxic that it was going to
kill people george w bush then published
the findings gave it out to the
mainstream media according with the epa
guidelines
and the epa announced the air is safe to
breathe even though they they just
there you go you hear epa and that is
god to the media
yeah the media government says you must
if the government says it
you cannot question it unless that's my
experience i was in new york city i was
breathing in that dust
and i'm pissed all right unless unless
it's trump
when trump was the government everything
he said was false
so we get that 2003. we get the 2001 we
get that 2003.
we get that uh all throughout the you
know even katrina there was massive lies
and and total psyops there with what was
happening on the ground
but look at last october what what
happened the new york post put out a
story hunter buy it in his laptop and
social media shut the story down
they said it was misinformation we can't
we can't allow this the spokesperson
from facebook goes on twitter and says
i'm blocking this information
these people this is a religion this is
cult-like behavior they don't care if
it's true they just
the the the the the priests of their new
religion have said it therefore they
must act and they shut the news
down then what happens after the
election oh that laptop story oh that
was true
yeah yeah like the media is going to
tell you the truth and
the wuhan lab story which they were
contradicting and now they're
contradicting themselves once again with
you know the admissions and the data
that's killers
clearly suggest that another thing i
wanted to bring up along with the golden
handcuffs
kind of analogy is what happened to
jesse ventura because he has an amazing
story of working for msnbc
in 2003 where he was rightly
anti-war he was against the war in
afghanistan he says there's no way i
will support it msnbc bought him a
full-time show
that he was supposed to do five days a
week and they asked him you're going to
be pro-war he said nope
what what happened he ended up finishing
his contract by not doing a single show
and he got a whole bunch of money for
lock you
yeah they locked him down he couldn't
say anything about it during that year
he couldn't do any interviews about it
they controlled every aspect of his
existence we even i i can't believe
we're saying this but but even chen
yuger had horrible experiences in msnbc
with them trying to control
i mean if you're trying to control chang
huger now and what
and what his talking points are and he
even came out rightfully so against
msnbc i mean wow you got
you got a major problem when it comes to
controlling the narrative controlling
the agenda
with closely psychologically approved
written talking points that are meant to
have an effect that effect predominantly
is
horrible for the general public and
really good for the special interests
for the billionaire class
and the multinational globalists that
benefit off of these horrible policies
that hurt people more than they help
them
one thing that people need to understand
about how these newsrooms work is that
when we hear the story about jesse
ventura people think that
some big boss is coming down to the
employees and saying you will report as
i tell you or
else that happens certainly but often
what they do is they just recruit people
they know to be either docile
or who already believe in the certain
ideology or agenda they're pushing
so they will go to they'll see someone
tweeting a bunch like tweeting nonstop
about palestine
saying israel is bad then they'll come
to them and say you're a really great
reporter would you like to be our middle
east reporter
knowing this person will frame every
story as anti-israel or pro-palestine
the inverse is true in many regards
depends on what the corporate entity
wants what kind of idea they want to
push
why bother hiring someone and then
trying to bribe them to say lies
when you could find someone who's
already willing to lie or is just really
dumb
anyway and they'll just say what you
want to be said
well at fox 26 every every word
that i would say on air was pre-approved
by my boss lee
first so there was there was no
tightly written scripts oh yeah so yeah
i would i would be sent out to cover a
story
i would write a script of of what i was
going to say on tv yeah
and then i would send it to her and she
would make changes if she wanted to and
send the script back to me and that's
what i would say
so this is happening on local news
imagine the bigger effects
on national news i mean you could only
imagine the level of control that goes
through there
so so you worked for fox corp
which is not fox news uh right i mean
fox news and fox
corp are both owned by the murdochs okay
but uh uh you know they're owned by la
uh
rupert murdoch lachlan murdoch is in
charge of fox corp
that's rupert's son and fox corp has the
the fox sports i believe fox sports and
then
and all the fox local owned stations so
so it is
still similar in that regard it's a
murdock company yeah
you'd think that the media would be
cheering for you calling out
fox right like these leftists that uh
say the daily beast would be saying
wow you've you've exposed the murdochs
for who they really are
trying to force you to lie or withhold
information
that's not what they're doing it's
really weird so i guess i'll just say it
i think you made the mistake
of uh giving an interview to the daily
beast right is that what happened oh
yeah
i mean i was being blown the media was
blowing me up on
monday i guess it was and i i guess
yeah tuesday and anyway i was just like
oh i was like looking at all these
emails and i was like looking
at what i reckon oh i recognize the name
daily beast that's a media outlet okay
sure yeah i'll talk here's my number and
and then uh this lady
we had a very nice conversation and then
uh
later someone's like oh there's a daily
beast article okay i see the headlines
it's an opinion piece i
i when i saw the headline i instantly
knew it was a spirit piece
i haven't even read the article if if i
i'm not interested in smear piece i
don't care
if someone wants to write a smear
whatever because i knew i know who i am
but uh it's just okay i wasted my time
on her whatever
i think i have the smear piece pulled up
i could be wrong it says wait this is
why a local fox reporter sabotaged her
career
ivory hacker told the daily beast on
tuesday that she's been terminated after
claiming on air the station has muzzled
her
this is an opinion piece yeah i didn't
even tell her i had been terminated i
told her this weird situation that
happened where
my bosses wouldn't tell me why they were
getting my
asking for my gear back and then i
received a text from a third party
saying that my boss told
him to tell me and i was like okay this
is this is weird and these people are so
nice to you and they're
so encouraging and they're so friendly
and they're so supportive
when they talk to you when they
interview you and then the stuff they
write your eyeballs pop out i mean we
were hanging out
around a couple journalists and like you
know we talked privately i was like that
guy's so full of utter
i can't say it here family friend you're
being vague because it's
this you're describing their situation
there's there's many of them and then
and a lot of them are like that guy's
gonna write the most horrible horrendous
hit piece
ever he is he is a disgusting
soul energy vampire and then people
around me people around me i know you're
talking about
that one girl she's like no they're
gonna be great he's such a nice guy he's
so friendly i'm like you could
you could feel and sense energy when
you're in tuned with it
and you just smell the scumbaggery
through a lot of these low-life
psychopathic individuals that have sick
twisted personalities that try to
befriend you
in this fake sick way in order to try to
destroy you
and and it's convincing a lot of people
who aren't who aren't like
experienced in this larger kind of
psychological
uh crazy trauma abuse that that they're
through
they're victims of it i'll reveal uh a
little bit about
um this one situation i think luke may
be referring to
there was a point where uh this
journalist who had agreed to do an
interview
left a wireless microphone um
and active at a table and saying bye
i'll see y'all later and people are
still sitting around
and it seemed like it was
meant to catch audio off the record when
we when he left
so he could record all of our
conversations i'm like there's a hot
microphone
a wireless hot microphone i forgot who
found it but i was absolutely
furious about it because who goes into
your home and leaves a hot microphone
inside of your home uh essentially
wiretapping us
uh when when we were having private
conversations but but the response
was oh it was just an accident we forgot
it was there it's no big deal
and so i'm not i'm not implying anything
by it i'll also uh say
it's it's it's not that i'm condemning
that completely outright
because look project veritas does
undercover reporting
but there there is something different
about you agreeing to sit down with a
journalist
who then tries to sneak a you know
microphone into your
into your house versus you get caught
undercover but i'm i'm not trying to
make the i'm not trying to act like
they're
completely different yeah but the the
issue is this guy came in with an agenda
we knew he had an agenda he was
extremely weasley and it was very
obvious the way he was asking questions
the way he was framing things
and too many people are are trusting of
these people to think
so i'll put it i'll put it this way when
when your video comes out with project
veritas what did the fox 26 say they
said it was a
falsely deceptively edited video and
misinformation or whatever
and that's what from a disgruntled
former employee
implying that be because i was fired by
fox i'm doing this everyone knows that's
false i did what i did live on tv while
i was working for fox
so it's an obvious false statement from
fox why would they make themselves look
so bad
but so you know what they try
they try to make that claim that when
you actually hear people saying these
words that they're
deceptively editing or whatever what
these journalists do
is they mission they mishmash quotes
from you so they can claim you literally
said them
and then they can publish whatever they
want they can use various tricks
so that i can take a quote from you and
then i can edit
dot dot and take a different quote and
mash them together so it makes it sound
like you believe in same things
they do that they do it all the time
people don't realize it because they
assume the media must be telling the
truth
it is easy to do there was a famous
comedian caught doing this in australia
with uh the reporter
uh ivy i forgot uh his exactly oh right
right right
secretly recorded the interview and i
had many media publications come to be
like we want to do an interview i'm like
okay
i'm going to record it too as soon as i
say that no that guy that we were just
referring to
was an absolute liar he did a huge hit
piece
uh we don't even want to mention him by
name we don't want to give him any more
attention
but but but again a lot of major
mainstream publications yeah major
mainstream publications and and they're
so i i smell these guys out like a
bloodhound because because it's so
telling it's it's so true and
and you must have to be like i it's just
hard to believe a lot of people have it
i'll give you i'll give you that they
wouldn't do that they wouldn't do it
themselves
i wouldn't do something that they were
doing i'll give you a i'll give you a
personal example and i'll call out the
journalist by name
andrew morantz he came to do an
interview with me at my apartment
writing for i think this was the new
yorker yeah as the new yorker
and i told him this bit big long story i
was i was talking for quite some time he
recorded actually
he took one story where i had a quote
and a different story with a different
quote
and he put them together it's gorgeous
to make completely different context
when vice cause because he it was about
vice
saw the quote they got mad and said that
is not true that quote isn't true
so the so what new yorker did was they
removed it but instead of admitting
fault
they said a quote from tim poole has
been removed because it contained errors
it wasn't my error but then what
happened was many people in media
started saying tim
lied and provided false quotes to the
new yorker because the new yorker should
have come out and said andrew marantz
andrew marantz is a lying two-faced
duplicitous
fake reporter who makes things up and
then doesn't
correct himself they could have done
that he could have said i'm sorry i made
a mistake and i missed me i
wrote down no type i was in accident i i
talked to him on the phone and i said
bro
you have a recording of this you came to
my house you turned the recorder on
and he was like too bad and i'm like
dude
the story i told you i've told on my
youtube channel before
the story that i told you i have told
numerous times
the quotes you mash together in no way
reflect the story i've told
and he was like well what we said about
removing it was was fair and true
it contained errors and i said yeah your
errors so put that it was your error and
he goes we're not going to do that
well yep welcome to the media and then
he's writing this like trivial
meaningless
drama that has absolutely no merit on
any real life
or or anybody's else existence and i'm
like
how do you call yourself a journalist
like how do you look at yourself in the
mirror
i know i know but but it's just hard to
fathom how someone could be
so duplicitous i had the southern
poverty poverty law center do the same
thing about me
take two different statements pull pull
them together
as if i was calling for a violent
revolution when i was specifically
calling for a non-violent evolution of
people waking up
informing themselves and helping out
their fellow brothers and sisters and
starting communities
they took two separate quotes put them
together as if i called for a violent
revolution and they put that on their
website
and they put me a part of their patriot
hit list and i'm like
oh my god like i never said this i
recorded a conversation
there's a video there's a youtube video
that they took it from and and the two
exact quotes are in two different
positions
and you just conflated it to try to make
me look like somebody i'm not
so that is deceptive editing yeah and
what project veritas is doing is not
deceptive editing and the new sound
bites i just put out today
a ton of direct from their own lips my
bosses
uh it spells out there was no
deceptive editing in what project
project veritas just released
okay go go listen to my new video it's
not real news anymore
they are corporations that seek to make
money off of infotainment
so project veritas a non-profit
doesn't make money off infotainment it
makes money off of exposing corruption
there you can argue that like the
southern poverty law center oh they make
money when they get these stories
accusing people of being racist oh
project veritas makes money when they
can
accuse someone of malfeasance i suppose
the difference is that project veritas
puts out videos where people's mouths
are moving
whereas southern poverty law center just
writes whatever they want kind of makes
things up actually
i will say outright makes things up they
had to retract an article about me and a
bunch of other
leftists which is really funny they
claimed i love it i love it southern
poverty law center you guys deserve this
one
they claimed that i was alt-right i'm as
most people know it's a meme because i
say i'm mixed race so often
and so i'm definitely not and they
claimed that i went to a holocaust
deniers conference
in iran which is like the most insane
thing to accuse someone of doing
like there's sanctions on this country
it's very difficult for americans to go
there
what are you talking about well it turns
out their source for this
was a conspiracy theory website for
holocaust deniers
that had been deleted and someone
archived
and the southern poverty law center
thought that was a credible source
to publish on their hate watch or
whatever and accuse me of actually going
there
and i remember talking to a lawyer on
the phone he's like now this is
important
you know if we're if there's going to be
a definition case here you need to tell
me if you've ever
if you've actually gone to something
like this or is there any way that this
could be construed as just his opinion
on the matter and i was like
i've never been to iran this is insane
it was a conspiracy theory website
and he's like okay all right and then
the southern poverty law center had to
retract that
their their goal is just to make money
off of shotgun and here's the really sad
thing is that the media puts a lot of
weight on
what the southern poverty law center
says when i was with the nbc affiliate
in minneapolis
uh there was a story that i was uh there
was a actually
anti-jihad protest happening that i was
assigned to
and the group who was protesting jihad
the the southern poverty
law center had listed as a terrorist
group i guess
or a hate group and uh and so
my my tv station actually told me don't
go interview them we don't want to give
a hate group
uh you know time time of day on camera
so because this little law center
said that this group is a hate group
they were about to get zero air time
they couldn't even explain themselves
why they were protesting jihad
and so i objected i was like absolutely
not
i am going to interview the people doing
this protest
and i'm going to interview the people
they're protesting and i'm going to show
exactly both sides
and i and when i put it together i had
both sides going back and forth and it
was incredibly compelling
and it turns out these these people were
uh
protesting the uh abuse of children
their abuse
uh protesting child marriages they were
protesting oppression of women
that's what these people were protesting
they were they were doing the opposite
of hate
they were standing up for women's rights
uh this group which by the way because
jihad uh there's different layers of
jihad
uh some people it's it's there's
different layers but
they were protesting the the radical
jihad
that's they were taking a stand against
it so but anyway i went and i went and
interviewed uh the islamic group that
that stands firmly with jihad too
it was very interesting story but i had
to put my foot down on that story
but a lot of reporters and news people
are pushovers you wanna
they don't wanna interject and say that
i wanna that i wanna interview this
person
because god forbid that oh she likes to
give hate groups the time of day no
we're trying to get to the bottom of the
truth on this
now when i worked for fusion there was a
pitch from one of our producers they
wanted to go
and film a clan training like like
actual clan members of which there's
very few there's a few thousand in the
country remaining i think
and people at fusion said we don't want
to give a hate group
coverage it's bad well vice ended up
doing something similar
they embedded with a bunch of alt-right
and white nationalists in
charlottesville and won a bunch of
awards for it
they actually had a reporter go into the
hotel room of white nationalists
allow these white nationalists to say
any and everything
and they won an award for it so long as
you are part of their cult
and you and and it for whatever reason
they accept it then you get to do it but
if you challenge them in any way
if you're not bending the knee to their
indoctrination then they'll remove you
and say you can't
it's just i feel like the media is so
easily manipulated i think there's a lot
of
innocent naive media members who don't
realize they're being
manipulated by groups like the southern
poverty law center
who who was a yeah peer pressuring them
into not talking to people who
were actually standing up for people for
individuals rights
after there were some lawsuits the splc
took down their slander of me because
they were getting sued left and right
but chris matthews of msnbc on his prime
time program
said that there's a rise of racist
right-wing tea baggers
with groups like we are change and i'm
like wait what are you kidding me so i i
made sure to doorstep and to confront
chris matthews face to face and i was
like hey chris
uh you called my independent news
organization that that
strives to do independent reporting a
right-wing racist
teabagging group explain yourself why
this is this is slander he's like i
never said that
i was like i was like yes you did he was
like no i didn't i don't know i don't
know what you're talking about
and i'm like okay here wait let me show
you the clip i literally pulled up the
clip
and as he's watching it he's like oh
crap and i'm like
answer your answer right now because you
slandered you lied about me to the
entire world
answer to it right now uh he had no
answer he was running away scurrying
away and i'm like
you know these people have no spines
they can't back up what they say
you can see the video right now we are
change chris uh
um sorry uh matthews chris matthews
i was confusing him with chris martinson
uh
chris but yeah yeah he sounds like my
bosses
every time i would confront them about
something they said they'd be like i i
didn't say that i didn't say that i'm
like well i recorded you in fact
um early on this when they really
started going after me it just
blindsided i was so confused um you know
i've had three years of
great relationships with my bosses made
no sense so i
i i did start recording to protect
myself but i actually
emailed them sound bites of themselves
to prove to them that i was recording
them and that they were lying
oh you're saying you didn't say this
here's your recording
that you said that and here's the thing
they continued to go after me even even
after i did that
but i have a funny story of how i first
heard about you it wasn't until after
this started happening that i first
heard about you
because i was you know i was zoned into
this the corporate media life i don't do
alternative media like you guys right
but uh so i had just i had it was like
two weeks after i had covered dr veron's
hydroxychloroquine
and they they came after me like none
other and i i went
i went to climb a mountain actually
because i do my hobby is is producing
these songs that i write because i
songs come to me through inspiration and
so i was like let me just do something
with these um so last year i just
started doing something with the music
that i wrote
um anyway i i had gone to colorado i had
written a
song like with the metaphor of mountains
in it so i wanted to shoot a music video
in the in the mountains uh like this is
my hobby let's go all out let's uh let's
film a music video too so i'm climbing
the mountain with my cameraman
um and i was telling him about this
insanity that i'm dealing with at fox
and uh how i'm having to record my
record them to protect myself
and um and he was like yeah he's like
you should just
get out of there as soon as possible and
and do be just like tim pool just do the
thing and uh i was like who's that and
and so then he told me about your
youtube
and then i saw this huge cult following
you have
and i was like wow and then i started
watching you and and i was like wow he
does
great youtube shows like this is this is
way more informative than our newscast
well now uh i'm trying to get more and
more journalists to do original
reporting
and so we just had a conversation with
one guy who's gonna do a lot of original
policy and culture stuff and it's gonna
be fantastic
because the i can't i can't count on
these other outlets to do it
you know it's it's it's funny how we
read a lot of these outlets and we
assume the news is true if it makes
sense
right cnn can put out a story right a
story today china sends 28 warplanes to
invade taiwan uh
china sent 28 warplanes to invade
taiwanese airspace
crossing over this like democracy line
or something and i just assume it's true
even though i know cnn lies all the time
i mean it's foreign policy why wouldn't
it be true it's the gallo man amnesia
effect the only problem is something
else
it's gel man and cognitive dissonance
because i can come out all day and night
and say cnn lies left and right they're
full of garbage
and then when i see a news story about
foreign policy i can only assume it's
true i'm like are they lying about this
now
well you know what probably but what am
i supposed to do it's all like it's
incredible when you really think like
how much how much of the news
i'm seeing is even factual and i think a
lot of this
a lot of it is not the journalists being
i mean a lot of journalists like i said
i think are
it's a combination of of lazy overworked
uh understaffed and and just
journalists who don't want to seriously
dig in i think
journalists are very easily manipulated
by their sources and i think some of
these fake news stories we're getting
are from aggressive sources who know how
to manipulate the reporter
have you ever read the book trust me i'm
lying by ryan holiday
no i haven't that guy's a genius you
should definitely check out that book
he talks about how easy it was to
manipulate the media one of my favorite
stories
from this guy ryan holiday check him out
he's awesome he's got a podcast where's
the daily stoic
yeah he's amazing he was promoting um
this guy tucker max
that's his name right tucker max i'm not
sure okay well was that his name luke
um i i don't know i'm looking yeah all
right we're getting a yes from another
camera
so uh he was promoting this guy and so
we came up with a really good idea
they bought a billboard and i could be
ruining i could be getting the story
wrong it's been a little while but
the story is basically this yeah they
put up a billboard
and then they personally vandalized the
billboard
then the next day he calls the radio
station and he goes
i'm driving down the street and i see
this billboard it's all vandalized
apparently it's tucker max guy's like a
bigot and a misogynist
so then the local media was like oh what
happened somebody vandalized
so the media got on it reported this
story giving free press attacker max
and then i guess they organized the
protest against themselves
so that they could generate press for
his book or movie or whatever and it
worked
wow it is so incredibly easy to
manipulate the press and i think that's
one of the big problems
when the media is decaying struggling to
make money as the landscape changes
and they're easily manipulated by
activist groups it just becomes an
activist apparatus
that's what it is it either either it's
going to sell
you know more waffles or whatever from
for from the from the
edgo corporation or whatever whatever
companies trying to sell so they got to
make the most punchy confirmation bias
news
or the activists have taken over like
the new york times you know we saw barry
weiss quit because she's like people in
new york times are like nervous
and it's being taken over by this
indoctrinate you know this these
indoctrinated this this cult
mentality and stuff so now what do we
get well when you read the news you're
probably just reading ideological
garbage
especially when it comes to domestic
stuff that's what it's been like for
millennia
like i think about julius caesar he'd go
to battle and then he'd write the
history report about what the battle was
about he'd write about who the enemies
were if he even wrote about him at all
and i mean we didn't even have what's
called a press until they invented the
printing press
which is like 500 year old technology
the idea of a press
and then even in the last 80 or 100
years have we had it
be you be allowed to speak out against
your government
like vocally with the american democracy
before you just get killed or put in
prison
but it but it is different you know
history being written by the victors is
not the same as
a massive media apparatus
writing things that serve a political
goal
in the end right if caesar was going out
telling everybody that he had already
won the war before it started
or that you know making up lies to to to
guarantee them and manipulate the public
that's more akin and i'm sure yeah they
would do that right exactly you want to
control the population
the difference is uh subtle i suppose
but
you make a good point it's always about
these powerful groups that want to
manipulate poor people
keep knowledge away from them so they
can't rise up so they can't protect
themselves
and so they're working basically as
serfs
or i guess back in rome slaves for the
empire
i think it goes back to i mean
conspiracy alert
the bible lucifer the lightbringer who
gave
the technology of light to the people i
don't know that that he did that well
they call him the lightbringer
so i'm trying to think why would they
call him the lightbringer well well if
he gives
you did he give electricity to people
like zeus had electricity and that
lightning
if you didn't read it you probably
shouldn't make assumptions about what
the story i'm all over the place
well if you look even at the history of
the printing press this was something
that was pushed back
by the establishment by the powers that
be that didn't want the printing press
because they didn't
want people reading certain scriptures
certain
documents because it empowered them and
whenever we have new technology come
it gives us a small window a small
opportunity to actually talk to one
another to find out what the world is
really like and
one of the most important powers you
could have in this world is con
controlling the free flow of information
and then you could usually correlate in
a society how free
the press is to how free the people are
and if people
are under a press that is tightly
controlled by special interests by
intelligence agencies
by people like udo ufket who
was a prominent german journalist who
openly talked about how the cia was
right in
writing press releases that the
mainstream media was just regurgitating
whenever you have a tightly controlled
mainstream media that just regurgitates
the talking points of the special
interest of the powers that be
you have a people that aren't free and
you expect me to do to do what research
the press release and actually write a
news story about it okay listen listen
i i'm busy i'm i've got ikea doing a
delivery later today so i want to go
home early
let me just copy and paste the press
release from joe biden
onto the website so i can leave already
heaven forbid i have to actually fact
check the men
that's uh that's how newsrooms operate
basically yeah because if one of the
facts turns out to
make joe biden look bad that could
cast accusations at you as a journalist
that's right and and that's why i'm
putting out these recordings especially
the one that i just put out tonight
because i want to show
why reported reporters self-censor
themselves to protect themselves they
want to avoid going through exactly what
i went through
a lot of reporters live in fear fear of
of losing their job or being uh hurt
some way by their bosses sub stack
do you have a sub stack yet no maybe
maybe you do that
um you know it's working out for glenn
greenwald and michael tracy right
okay someone was sending me something
about that um
people can throw you a couple bucks and
you just write stories
and then you're your users you're you're
supported by your readers who expect you
to do a good job
and if you do a bad job you lose their
support now there's
there's there's a problem there too
obviously if you write a bunch of
articles talking about how trump is you
know god emperor obviously you'll get
trump superfans who will sign up and the
moment you say he's not
many of those people will leave so
there's still a confirmation bias
problem memberships as well
that's right that's what we saw with the
aclu see the aclu defended the right of
the uh
defended the right to free speech of the
unite the right people
in charlottesville and they got attacked
for it and panicked
they had gained so many new members
donating monthly because they challenged
trump on his travel ban
so then when they defended unite the
right they started bleeding users like
members like crazy who are like oh
you're supporting bigots so then the
aclu flipped and now they're this weird
organization that
claims to protect free speech but very
much does not defend
civil rights at all we call it the
anti-civil liberties union
yeah because they they they've certainly
become a vile disgusting organization
that actually seeks to suppress rights
and not support them the same is true
for free press my favorite my favorite
one is freepress.net
what what do you think they're all about
well they had a big campaign to make
sure alex jones was banned from the
internet
because you know that's what a free
press is all about banning wrong think
wow the modern era is a creepy time you
know but i'm glad that we can have these
conversations the very least
uh for as long as we can have them
because you know we're constantly under
threat of getting banned
a lot of people don't think they're like
oh tim says he's gonna ban it's never
gonna happen it's like dude
we've already got a warning on this
channel we're seeing what they're doing
to stephen crowder
we're seeing what they're doing to
smaller smaller channels it just so
happens that i'm a bit more milk toast
than many of those people but it's only
a matter of time
the narrative must be protected at all
costs what youtube and many of these
other
uh big tech companies want is they want
to homogenize
perspective they want to get rid of
anything that falls outside of the
narrative so they can easily control it
it's like micah brzezinski said it's our
job to control exactly what people think
she said it verbatim let's just pull it
up again so no one can say i'm lying
from grabian
our job is to control exactly what
people think oh she came out later and
said no no
i meant not shut up lady we know what
you think you are we know what you think
you're doing we know what msnbc is doing
or cnn
they lie yeah and she uh her father was
a very prominent person that played a
very key role in american politics in
american geopolitics
sabinif brzezinski that was jimmy
carter's presidential advisor
a part of the trilateral commission
bilderberg council council on foreign
relations and really pulled a lot of
strings
when you look at organizations like the
council on foreign relations there's a
reason why they allow so many
journalists a part of their secretive
club
there's a reason they have so many off
the record meetings between people in
high positions of power
and the mainstream media and they work
kind of in tandem here and that's why
you know we have to understand here
there's so much power there's so much
cause and effect by information and when
you could tightly control it
you could do so many amazing things but
you could also do so many
awful things and when you look at the
history of the mainstream media i mean
if there's a
if there's an honest good working
youtube moderator out there which i
doubt but if there is
just please please look at the record of
the mainstream media and look how many
times they were wrong
and look how many times independent
media has been right
calling things out small mom and pop
operations
have been calling things out correctly
for so long we finally have the
opportunity to be heard
and that opportunity is closing down
every single day with
algorithms de-platforming
demonetizations there's so many things
standing in the way
and that's why you know what you're
doing with timcast.com
what other people are doing starting
their own platform starting their own
services
uh and your guys's participation in it
is absolutely crucial because you need
to not only vote with your dollar but
vote with your attention
with your clicks with your shares and
and it means
everything and i really think we're
seeing that happen i think that
the ratings and the and the readers and
everything is is moving away from the
establishment media to the alternative
media
this is the era of the independent
journalists i don't think we're the
alternative media anymore i think
collectively we're getting more
more traffic aren't we exactly that's
right so
so eve but they consider they i think
they would consider you an
alternative but here's yeah but that's
like an old man saying get off my mind
exactly but and that who cares what the
establishment
anyone thinks because the viewers the
actual citizens
are gravitating to the truth seekers
yeah you know
i think one of the biggest problems that
we have in society
people getting scared of what the
establishment thinks who cares
literally who cares or having a hit
piece on them which now is a badge of
honor
now i see the mainstream media trashing
someone i'm gonna be like okay well let
me do a little bit of research and not
believe them point blank because there's
usually an agenda to try to trash or
bring someone down
or even just an ego to egotistical push
to
bring someone down for for the algorithm
so there's a lot of manipulation
happening behind the scenes being aware
of it being conscious
being able to take a few moments to
breathe and take a step back and look at
the larger picture
is something that more and more people
need to do and sadly
you know the mainstream media doesn't
like that they don't want you thinking
they don't want you conscious they don't
want you in a state that you're not in
the constant
fear state that you're not in a constant
stress state that you're not in a
constant consumer state because bad
consumers is bad for business bad for
advertisers
bad for the overall agenda it's so
interesting the harder they push for
that
they're getting the opposite of what
they're trying for it's
freaking people out and causing them to
think for themselves and seek out
answers for themselves
but there's there's a there is a weird
divide where some people
i think know something's wrong but they
refuse to speak out because they're
cowards
right there's a hundred percent in the
media absolutely
so uh you know what man i'd love for the
people who recognize what's happening to
finally step out step
up speak out uh be brave and contact
james o'keefe 100 and expose corruption
and let me tell you
we've already heard from several
insiders in newsrooms who are up
are saying they're ready to to kind of
follow in my footsteps
so there's gonna be more uh exposes are
you are you
uh if if these people fall through and
look i'm gonna be there for them i know
james is gonna be there for them
like whoever i'll hire everybody
seriously there's so many
there's so many people who are ready to
hire you and donate to you and support
you if you want to
break away from this media which is
really a cult and
cults worship something and what they
worship is the narrative break break
free be a true journalist it's really
hard to be a true journalist in the in
the corporations in some
in some beats in some news beats you can
do great journalism like the crime beat
they would let me cover crime
no problem other other beats okay now i
don't know about that so much anymore i
mean
uh there's this really funny story where
they said that the the ant there's
there's a lot of memes going around
about
stop asian hate and the perpetrators
being black men
and this report i think is from nbc news
said but when we actually
looked at all known suspects in the
media we found 75
were white and therein lies the problem
many outlets have straight up said they
will not reveal
the race of an individual if it would
you know produce a harmful stereotype or
contribute to one
so you want to cover crime don't be
surprised if you know
there was this moment in sweden where a
guy committed a crime
and so the media pixelated his face and
then changed the tone
behind the pixels because we want to
avoid racist stereotypes it's like uh
or recently it was the austin there was
a shooting in texas in the newspaper
didn't want to describe the suspect
that was that large that was that large
that people were looking for that
shot up a nightclub and and then and the
newspaper refused to even to talk about
who he was
i had a co-worker who did that in
minneapolis when i was with nbc
she covered a crime story this guy is on
the loose after committing a vicious
crime
typically when we're doing it at the end
of the story we say hey guys please look
out for this guy here's his full
description call police if you see him
she refused to do that part of the story
helping catch this criminal
because he was black
and she didn't want to she didn't want
to say
say a description like that and she now
works for cnn
oh wow cnn probably recruited her the
moment they heard that she did that they
were like that's the kind of
no but i'm not kidding they probably
said someone who will just say what
she's told to say without arguing
without needing to be bribed
i mean look you get a real journalist
and how much money you got to pay them
to
to bend them you get an idea log and you
can be like we're actually docking your
pay because you're racist
please go tell the world and say okay
cnn just hired that guy that got caught
spanking it
on a webcam i mean they have no
integrity at all and if you really
this is this is advice for the viewers
out there if you want to see what
someone
someone is about look at the fruits of
their labor cnn
attacks grandmothers who make facebook
pages attacks
other journalists attacks people like us
independent journalists
they punch down when you look at
independent media when you look at other
people that
do actual reporting they're punching up
they're going after actual
institutions with actual power that
actually have an effect
on your life you look at who gets
targeted that's
how you should judge a person and judge
a news organization by
it's not just the media i mean it's the
cultural left the democratic party
what are they going after this tiny sect
of trump supporters as evil and it's
like you guys control all the cultural
institutions in the government
you're the big guy stomping on a little
guy but i absolutely love
how cnn went to the home of an old woman
and started yelling questions at her in
full view of her house and address
and that's okay social media twitter got
no problem with it james o'keefe
blurs the address and confronts somebody
banned
all right that was very project readout
i believe that's what got their their
official account banned
then eventually they twitter does ban
james o'keefe you know i think it's
fairly obvious
james o'keefe project veritas all of the
great reporters
they do great journalism empowered by
people like you who blow the whistle and
call out the malfeasance
and that's really scary to to the
establishment
there's it's like they defeated
journalism
they were the these these evil uh uh
demonic
individuals were probably laughing that
journalism had finally been conquered
and was over
then along comes small independent
channels small organizations like
project veritas and they grow and
becoming more successful
now look how panicked they are they
never know if whoever they're talking to
could be undercover for project veritas
i've never cared you know why the sing
the things i say privately
are the same things i say on this show
100 exactly
that's how i feel now don't get me wrong
like the narrative of you have nothing
to hide you have
nothing to worry about is very bad when
it comes to an authoritarian police
state
but you look at these companies and how
worried they are about how someone could
be veritas and the security protocols
they got to do and it's kind of like
be honest like if if somebody from
veritas secretly recorded somebody who
worked here and said something dumb i'd
be like well i guess i said something
dumb
i don't know there you go exactly
exactly yeah
yeah media's uh it's kind of like
they're functioning as a paramilitary
corp
the media like they're an arm of the
secretive because if you're in the
military you can't
say whatever you have you have clearance
and classification and you're under
strict orders not to
and it's all it seems like they've been
they've been co-opted to do
information the job of the military it
really is i mean generational warfare
and now here these people are whipping
people into shape and
getting them in line and telling them
what to think and what to do you know
what's funny is uh when it comes to
second the second amendment
you get these uh these anti-gun
democrats who are like do you really
think you're gonna go to war with the
united states government they got
nuclear missiles
and the first response is you can't
occupy a street corner with a nuclear
missile are you dumb
you look at afghanistan vietnam it's
it's an individual with a gun which can
control
a neighborhood or a building or
resources and then i think about it
you don't need to occupy the street at
all if you occupy the minds of the
people
if the only information they can get
access to tells them whatever you want
them to think
well there you go you know and i'll
mention this because i used to watch
star trek the next generation all the
time
i've seen every episode a million times
but before the show and people commented
i should watch stargate
sg1 so i started watching stargate sg1
and in this show advanced aliens pretend
to be gods
to control and manipulate human
populations to use them as slaves
that's what i'm talking about dude so i
brought up lucifer earlier
just saying well so but the idea is they
don't need to to use weapons to
subjugate these people
they've convinced them of an ideology
and those people are willingly serving
now
i think that i think that we're doing
that without realizing it i mean we're
working
100 well the alien disclosures are
coming very soon
it's gonna be nothing with the new york
post just reporting quote ufos could
threaten u.s security politicians say
after capitol hill briefing
i'm suspicious that's a distraction yeah
yeah when you have barack obama and neil
degrasse tyson
talking about how there's ufos out there
and how we need more money for the
military
yeah you should start asking yourself
some questions about what's really going
on here because uh
it's not usually what they say right
yeah oh they're using the ufos as an
excuse to get more
military barack obama made a specific
statement saying
you know we're going to find out that
aliens are real and this is going to
mean we're going to have to increase the
military budget
that's his own words uh from but what if
aliens
are real could be there's there's a
possibility in there we have to be
intellectually honest
i i think there is a big chance that
they are but what if obama is basically
ozzie mendius
staging a fake alien invasion to force
people to unite
right and and give up their freedoms
like in the pandemic
i just hope that's not the case you know
yeah well we'll see time will play out
but the best friend you could have
is skepticism in this modern day and age
where information
is that block 17 you know firearms uh
there's a reason the first amendment was
first second amendment is second uh they
protect each other they're very integral
and
people in gated communities and private
bodyguards shouldn't be telling people
that they need to be disarmed
i think i think people need to become
more responsible you know as much as we
can rag on the authoritarian move for
the great reset i can certainly i can
certainly say
while authoritarianism the manipulation
of people through through lies and
deception all that's wrong
hey man people need to start becoming
more responsible for themselves
self-reliant
everybody should go out you know be like
more responsible for the food they eat
we grow grass in our lawns that's a
stupid idea we should have gardens with
vegetables that you can grow and you can
be responsible for some of the food you
eat
you should exercise you should read
books get away from the cities pollute
less
be you know more in tune with what it's
like to actually survive and be
responsible for yourself
and you know what this criticism is
mostly towards people in cities because
the people in the rural areas basically
know all this already
the people in cities live in cubicles
stacked on top of each other in cities
that smell like sour milk and then
complain about the problems they've
created
these people need to to get with the
program and learn how to be
human again you practice what you preach
when did you move out here
we're in the country well so someone
chatted beginning the show that
you know i only decided to move out to
middle of nowhere once i had money
and it's like i i moved to the middle i
was in i was in far
i was on a farm in the redlands which is
basically 40 miles outside of miami i
don't understand like it's the most
rural place ever
but i lived in a farm with chickens like
this was this is 2015 that's when i was
working for fusion i didn't want to be
in a city back then
and so i did move back to the new york
area
and then slowly moved away and now we're
more in the middle of nowhere but not in
the middle east of nowhere i will say
once starlink goes live we'll probably
go way more middle of nowhere
but the we're trying to strike the
balance between people can fly here
pretty easily
and we're kind of far away from you know
big cities
so we've got a big garden we're growing
vegetables we've got chickens
man so we got one chicken it was a
rehome laying eggs every day
we got too many eggs already because we
don't eat eggs every day so we had like
six today and i was like wow so i'd be
like i gotta eat these eggs
and then but we've got six other we've
got five other chickens turns out one of
them is a rooster
so we're going to have tons of eggs all
the time we're going to have like six
eggs per day
and that's that's just from the chickens
eating the bugs and the bugs eat the
grass and they give us eggs
being responsible more for ourselves
that's that's what i'm saying you know
we we are getting uh solar panels
installed we're we're trying to be more
energy efficient we're uh we have our
own water system we want our own
electrical system
when i talk about environmentalism i
mean it you know we we we we have
occurred oh yeah but we use these
these corn plastic biodegradable cups
that aren't like regular cups
you look at these celebrities that talk
about climate change they don't actually
mean it they fly in private jets
they they live in these big mansions
they consume ridiculous ridiculous
amounts of power
they buy beachfront property while
claiming the beaches are are going to be
wiped out by rising ocean water
and i'm like that's just hypocrisy you
know what
too many people live in these cities
they're they're gluttonous
they do very little work in exchange for
tons of money while
thinking they're poor and i'm not trying
to be mean to people live in cities who
think they're poor
but man if you live in a big city and
you can walk outside and go for a buck
get a cheeseburger
you're you're doing better than 99.9
percent of the entire planet
and now they've they've lived in such a
way that they've lost touch with what
it actually means to be responsible for
your own health and safety and security
they've deferred everything to the
mainstream media to tell them what to do
and what to think
and then they complain about it they
complain about the system instead of
realizing they're being lied to and it's
time to roll up your sleeves and
actually do some hard work
amen i think people are getting that
more than
more people than ever are not trusting
the media
yeah and i'm optimistic you know i i i'm
fairly pessimistic in terms of talking
about war
and and conflict and especially with you
know joe biden saying
the fed you know people should snitch on
their family members and the feds
wanting to go after
extremists but i think about hey
timcast.com we're doing really well
we're hiring people we've got a newsroom
just launching
there's a lot of difficult you know
challenges ahead but i'm
i'm 100 confident we're going to succeed
and if and and
operating under that assumption what
does the next five ten years look like
a large independent news outlet
challenging the lies in the mainstream
media and helping clear away the noise
helping people understand what's
actually happening and choose for
themselves how they should live and how
they should vote
that makes me optimistic i mean we're
doing something here we're going to
bring in more people to do more things
everybody else should
should do the same agreed yeah we're
working on uh
what have you ever heard of the
fetaverse no what's that it's uh
it's like different social networks like
mastodon and other
types i don't know there's a few other
ones that where they all interoperate
all these different social networks so
like you could you could be on like
minds and i could be on youtube and i
could subscribe to your minds channel
and then tim could be on twitter and
subscribe to me on youtube from twitter
and then we can all have like our own
feeds whereas they'd be like your
website my website tim's
with all of our own independent sites
very cool oh my gosh
yeah yeah that's going to be the future
of independent media because up until
internet video they're what independent
media i don't know
what it was alex jones screaming in his
on the radio
then it was youtube but then we realized
that it's not independent if it's on
if it's on corporate yeah it was
publicly access alex jones got to start
by literally going down to the local
public access station that
filmed on some cable news channels and
that was where he got his start so this
will be the next public access
but we're gonna have to get off of isps
that'll be the big next step after we
get off the social
internet service provider so like
verizon
um could shut down your internet access
if they didn't like
amazon with uh parlor right yeah amazon
has the hosting service so then you also
have your dns
uh which could shut down your so you've
got to get off the isps and can go oh i
see
wow oh my gosh um yeah it's a big big
problem i mean it's
so we're wired in it's going to be yeah
we've got to figure that out
the goal is to create an open source
software
that the average person can just put on
put on like
you you go to a server company you know
a a server
service then you install this program
which gives you a basic
subscription service website so imagine
sub stack but it's yours
it's your website with your open source
code operating this
and then people who like your content
can become members
sign up to pay so that you can you can
do your own work the goal of this is
let's say you start a sub stack which is
where a lot of these journals have gone
well they can ban you
they can say we don't like what you're
saying imagine you start a patreon
oh they will ban you because they've
already done that to a lot of people
so we want to make something that's
harder to ban not impossible to ban i
mean
your your uh domain registrar
or your server company they could still
terminate services to you but it
eliminate it makes it harder to do
so you know hopefully we get to that
point where people can just
buy buy server space buy a domain drop a
program into their server and execute it
and then boom they've got a functioning
website
add some graphics done you probably will
happen as we'll have mesh networks and
our phones will be
our servers i think that'll be the
future wow
yeah that'd be that'd be a great idea
there's uh there's actually apps that do
this
so i went on a cruise several years ago
no
there's no phone service so what they
did was everyone would turn on bluetooth
and you downloaded this app where it
connects every phone to each other
so if you send a message to your friend
who's on the other side of the cruise
your phones will your phone will hit
this guy's phone with that guy's phone
and then bounce around
all the way until it makes it to the end
and then that guy gets the message
so each phone was acting like a cell
tower it's amazing yeah they did
something similar
at burning man but but just very
curiously i mean
you just did this do you have any plans
moving forward we're going to be going
from here
uh i i want to continue doing
independent journalism somehow um
i'm just i'm really i have a bad taste
in my mouth about corporate news i
i don't want to be a part of any i
really am craving
some solitude right now like just being
alone for a while i am working on this
really important story
that i mentioned to you guys of
finishing bringing this full circle that
what started with dr verone last august
and and fox clamping down so hard on
that story
i'm digging back in and saying let's get
to the bottom
what have we learned in in a year
let's talk to the researchers the
doctors and i even got a one-on-one with
world health work
guys wow yeah so i'm looking forward to
putting i've already
shot this story i'm going to put it out
so i'm
i'm already working on on this first
independent report
and um i i want to continue doing
journalism
you know and i want to yeah i just want
to be authentic
and and not owned by anyone and i just
want some freedom and peace
and and i i do need to figure out how to
monetize myself
um but you know i'm i'm open to a lot of
things
um i want to keep doing journalism but i
also i
i love my music and i have all these
songs that came like through
inspiration like a lot of my songs come
in my sleep it's just like completely
inspired so i want to just
work on my songs because i haven't had
time with
all the chaos that happened with fox i
and um
and then fitness is another thing i'm
passionate about and i actually
when when i really was like okay it's
i've got to get out of fox i actually
bought a
personal training program and i was like
oh i'm going to get certified as a
personal trainer
because i enjoy fitness and um
you know why not monetize something you
enjoy so
i'm i'm open to doing like a few
different things and just
you know continuing to do what i'm
passionate about
right on yeah well how about we take
some super chats if you have not already
smash the like button it really does
help the channel and subscribe to this
channel
share the show with your friends and
don't forget go to timcast.com because
we will have a bonus segment around 11
pm is usually when it goes up
that'll be for members only but your
membership helps support the
uh fierce independent journal journalism
which we will be expanding upon
right now cassandra fairbanks is leading
the charge but we've been going through
resumes we've been having phone calls
and we're probably gonna be adding
people very very soon
and the new website will be up within
the next month or so so it's gonna be
beautiful and amazing
and you guys rock let's go to these
super chats all right
cryptic says tim check out junius maltby
youtube channel he calls out the fed and
talks about
sound money very very cool jacob wilson
says they are taking away your
notifications
i know yeah a lot of people don't get
notified that we go live anymore
it's weird i don't think it's weird i
think it's absolutely on par for what
youtube is doing especially when we're
hosting conversations like this why does
that work so you click the subscribe you
click the bell button and click it to
all notifications and then you still
don't get it still don't get it still
is that because other things are
prioritized no it's because youtube
is pretending to actually be fair
to think of it i haven't gotten
notifications about you recently
and we're we've got i don't i'm not
gonna name anybody but we've got a
really big week coming up with a with a
bunch of people that's like
we're gonna be you ever see those videos
of like the russian dudes who climb on
cranes and like dangle with one arm
that's basically basically what we're
doing next week in turn in terms of
youtube banning us so we're bringing we
got some big names
and we're basically going to be dangling
off the edge of that crane confident we
can pull ourselves up and not get banned
but uh
conversation's got to happen like i have
my limits i always say like there are
some things that youtube doesn't allow
you to talk about we'll be very careful
because
i don't want to sacrifice 99 of the
conversation for one percent
but there's a limit youtube saying you
can't say the sky is blue or two plus
two equals five is a limit it's like nah
we can't we can't get to that point we
gotta have real conversations
all right she be geebies says any chance
i i could get a shout out for the horror
show i co-host called
visited by voices we spotlight
lesser-known creators in the community
hey there you go shout out
here's good news frank perez says tim we
can officially constitutional carry in
the great state of texas starting
september 1st
it's about time geez seriously surprised
yeah oh i've got a story on that one
yeah they definitely they assigned me to
that story when it goes going through
the legislature there because you know
i'm a texas reporter
and it was all about racial groups
how will racial groups react to this
legislation
and they actually they assigned me to my
um
one i do one story on how women are
reacting and affected and when uh
on how black people are are reacting and
they it was weird but we can get in
people like guns
they they actually sent me specifically
to um
third ward which is the the known to be
like the blackest part of houston and
then to a barber shop specifically
too to get reaction on on guns
wow all right we got black tsar he says
due to crt
die training talent has been leaving our
armed forces
some quit and form local militias those
are facts now suppose some of them left
believing crt
but came to pro-white conclusions that's
what the government fears
that the genie is out of the bottle it's
a really interesting point good point
yeah identitarianism can be for any race
and critical race theory basically
teaches that
it tells people to segregate or i should
say applied racial theory is what we're
seeing at these schools
they're telling children to do and
believe things and it results in white
people saying okay
and there was a school district in
california that actually said they
wanted to trigger a white racial
awakening
in children okay great jacob richardson
says i can verify that the
anti-extremism and wokeness crt and
diversity trainings are causing people
to leave the military
example me captain usmcr
wow not surprised yeah well who's left
a bunch of woke cultists that's right
yes men
do anything a lot of people mentioning
that constitutional carry was just
signed into law i think that's
absolutely fantastic
we have that up in new hampshire and
it's pretty awesome nice
cole gibson says give this girl a job
i'd actually i'll actually subscribe
subscribe to your website if i can
listen to her reporting you want to talk
about backbones
that's right there's a lot of comments
saying that
people are saying it jake wiggington
says my mother is a nurse who worked the
entire pandemic
the hospital she worked at used this
drug very often and it saved many lives
the entire
time interesting i wonder what drug
that's talking about hmm
you should always talk to your doctor no
no no i mean
i'm really bothered by this because my
friend who got who got
sick it was like he didn't
he didn't go through an analysis of his
medical history and so
i i will say i think to be fair look i
know i know
almost everybody i know like from back
home got vaccinated totally fine
and i've got one friend uh two people i
know one one friend and someone close to
my family who have been who've gotten
sick
and i think it's because they didn't do
a proper assessment of their medical
histories
and when i talked to him about it i
actually think we found
you know the reason that was like hey
this is why you probably got sick this
is you know why they had a breakthrough
case
like they got coveted after vaccination
before
okay so uh there have been some stories
about that that if you
so there was there have been doctors who
have said if you get covet you have to
wait before you get the vaccine
i'm not telling you to do anything okay
youtube calm down i'm saying there was a
story that was published far and wide
and so i had a friend who got sick and
then shortly after i got vaccinated and
he had an adverse reaction and i'm like
it may have been because you needed a
second opinion a doctor who would have
looked at your history and said
oh whoa whoa like let me you know so
that's why i always tell people talk to
a doctor
talk to a second doctor make sure you're
getting sound medical advice don't get
it from
from political shows all right let's see
east f says luke demand that everyone
comment on
the luke demand that everyone comment on
the atf's website regarding the ruling
what is a receiver and the banning
pistol braces see
guns and gadgets video rise to the
challenge on youtube for more info
love the show yeah the atf released uh a
guidelines that's
very complex very big about their
proposals for uh
you know firearms and receivers and and
and
all these different things and they're
actually taking comments from the
general public
uh about it so people are asking people
to get involved which
um your choice but i think it's it's
going to be interesting to see what the
atf does
there's a lot of comments just saying to
higher yeah wow i
can't just read everything we might get
enough super chats to do it yes uh if we
get enough super chats to pay her salary
then yeah then it's a no-brainer all
right let's see
that means a lot that means a lot it's
so interesting that the
reaction from the audience about about
this from viewers
it's been nothing but love yeah that the
friends in the media who have been like
brave enough to reach out to me after
this
have sent me sympathy and i was like
what are what are you sympathetic about
i'm
doing great yeah i'm doing better than
ever fox was
a prison isn't it isn't it amazing how
when you do the right thing
good things happen yeah weird there
there was that the facebook
whistleblower for james o'keefe wanted
to get a half a million dollars
right i i i think that's absolutely
wonderful
if you tell people listen if you come
out and expose the corrupt there's a
support network
and i'm pretty sure half a million
dollars is better than where he was
before
and i'm glad to hear it i'm glad to hear
it absolutely people want to help them
out
you guys if you're a media member come
on out we'll support you
send uh uh be brave go to project
veritas and and
expose there is a huge demand for legit
bold uh truth seekers so if you get out
of the corporate media
you know people are going to want to
tune in to you this is so important
because people are so scared about
speaking up so i'm really glad that
you're sharing your story because we
really need to motivate people to come
out and be like yeah this is actually
happening and when you do you email as
far as i know veritas
tips at protonmail that sounds right
yeah you can send an anonymous
tip to them or if you know send them
your contact info that's right
uh you'll probably get a phone call from
james james o'keefe is very excited
about this story right now
he'll probably get a personal call i
don't know sweet one of the most
effective people fighting
in the culture war and just in general
for
truth in media i suppose i think it
would be silly to assert that
everything veritas does is perfect
that's ridiculous nobody is so
the media hyper focuses on faults or any
kind of hole they can possibly find
but man i look i look at a lot of the um
anti-establishment woke or whatever
there's very few people who are fighting
as hard as james's and doing a good job
of it especially
so i'm eternally grateful that vertos
exists
all right benjamin dine says the
establishment wants to make sure the
public panics the right
time so they can provide the appropriate
insight into the situation
so the public will just believe whatever
they say without question potentially
i think they want people to panic at the
right time so they can game the market
so they can force all the people to lose
their resources they can buy them up
and then crank the prices up and sell
them high and that's the game they play
wait who's saying
one set who's he saying one set the
establishment okay the establishment
media
want wants panic as much as possible all
the time
yeah there's a story story every day
they would love that
and that's why they have loved kovid yep
yeah like the
the the cnn guy yeah gangbusters that's
what he said right
and they loved the death count and they
were hoping it was going to go up and
they had it on the screen
guys let me tell you when covid first
came in march last year
they my my news team was reporting the
the case count and the death numbers and
i was getting
those numbers as well as the recovery
rates from all the local counties
and i was actually shocked looking at
the sensationalism in the media at that
time and then
looking at the recovery rate that i was
like oh people are recovering really
quick because initially it was like
wait do you ever get over this or you
know and i was and i in in our morning
editorial meeting in our board room i
said susan to my boss
we need to we need to put the recovery
rate on the tv too
to give the full picture um and she she
was adamant against that that shocked me
yeah
she said no we don't want the recovery
rate up there wow wow evil
yeah it was until like weeks later when
more pressure was put on her she finally
put it up
you ever see that meme where it was like
type in three random numbers
and like a city and co or type in three
item numbers and covered and you'll find
stories and so like
i did works yeah like like oh it was 300
random numbers and cases or something
and the stories there's just always
something it's it's really weird any
three random numbers
nine obviously not starting with zero
but you know
wow gets the clicks man all right
cassius cam says hey gang your friend
from the lumber mill
millennials are still soft and won't
work been working twelves for three
months and weekends
i'm also an ancap rap artist luke can i
send you some of my videos on
ig i won't disappoint you yeah uh you
could email me at
info we are change dot org i'm actually
answering those emails
info we are change.org
geraldo oliveira says governor desantis
announced florida is sending state
troopers to texas and arizona to assist
with the border crisis
this is an early sign of states
consolidating like the states
with states like the blue state people
moving to conservative areas
that's scary i love it the states taking
responsibility amongst themselves and
basically separating from the fed
so scary did you did you do the trick
dude i'm looking at
the most ridiculous graphic this is the
new cases and deaths from the
coronavirus it was january 10th is when
it started to go down
january 10th that's four days after
biden was sworn in is that right january
6th no that's not what is after january
6th 20th january 20th
but did you type the three numbers yeah
it just gave me a bunch of i typed 7 51
23 cases covet and it gave me
seven seven seven fifty one and twenty
three cases coveted
i what do you mean just type in line six
one nine
oh three single digit numbers yeah yeah
yeah what were you what were you you
were
doing like what are those compound
numbers yeah
so like six space one no no like 619
or 124 or 736. there was a meme where
you could like just type that in and
then
google would give you a story for every
random number maybe we could talk about
on the after show that
we'll look into it yeah this is crazy
wow bob oh yeah oregon covid
19 updates 713 new cases i just typed
713
what is going on this is the most
propagandized
no i think it's because it's ever
happened media was tracking every single
number
every single day maryland reports 712
right
because it was the shock content they
wanted every number every time exactly
exactly we'll we'll look into this we'll
we'll pull it up for the bonus
bonus segment bob simarczyk says splc
put we are change on the list and
effectively dissolved
we are changed seattle thanks to luke
for marching on
someone has to do it and uh yeah they
try to intimidate you they try to make
you afraid and
if you're not afraid you could continue
on um they want you in a constant
negative low vibrational state
of panic fear anxiety don't let them win
that's right right coast crypto says hey
tim talking about creating culture
i was a heroin addict for eight years
just celebrated 16 months clean
i'd love to do something with you to let
people know there's a way out so many
people are suffering we could help so
many
well we got a lot of work to do but you
can always send your email to pitches at
timcast.com where we
have somebody who goes through them and
then tries to figure out what we're
capable of doing
there's a lot of things we want to do so
also about what we can do
i'm hoping within five years we're doing
all of it i hope so movies sitcoms
all that stuff okay okay hire her hire
her higher
i love that machismo joe says ivory we
are not a cult we are guerrillas
glad to hear you're here when are you
joining the beanie compound yeah
all right all right geez
everyone's just saying the same thing
thanks guys
let me scroll down a little money here
we go andrew pawlowski says hey tim
i just got an invite to clubhouse it's a
talk only social media site that has
huge potential to change culture
i have several invites if you want one
just say yes and i'll message you on ig
yeah clubhouse was really big and now
it's no one uses it anymore what
happened with it
it was a it was a fad everybody was
doing these talk rooms and then
eventually they got bored of them
and now no one in the us really uses
them anymore so they kind of
you know but i appreciate the offer
okay the magellanium says hey tim big
fan from canada
thanks for keeping me sane in this dark
age of information keep it the good
fight and god bless
thank you appreciate it
guam tech says tim your one wheeled
skates are not a good design
look into tri skates or even aggressive
if you want to do tricks
also looking for some anyone to come to
the compound and rep some blading
um so i have this photo i bought i got
amazon recommended these weird things
just like a bike wheel
yeah and then you wear a brace like on
your legs so you have the bike wheel
like
on the left and like outside of your
legs there is a little training wheel
and it's just like the most ridiculous
thing ever it doesn't really work
i need to see a picture yeah it's on my
instagram so that's what they're talking
about
uh guam tech we actually are having some
bladers come out
not this weekend but next weekend we're
gonna have bmx
scooter and bladers coming out and we
are going to film a vlog where we just
get
interdisciplinary trick doing at the
compound it's gonna be a whole lot of
fun i'm excited for it
200 2007 shockwave says just got over
from watching viva barnes and they
mentioned this
not that i was unaware of you guys to
begin with well they mentioned our show
or
cool appreciate it with james matt
bowler says been listening
live nearly every day for a while now
yet i'm finding myself wondering for the
first time
where's ian i'm right here friend he
said
he's listening just listening taking it
in i i'm
very um taken by ben franklin lately and
he
was noted i think when he went to the
first constitutional convention he said
nothing the entire time
really good for him listening underrated
leor i have to read all of these
comments
leor engelstein says timothy daniel
poole you better bring miss hecker on
board right now if not i will consider
taking my money from tim cass and
walking away from denzel
your mom my that that must be your
mother with the full name there
leo engelstein is not my mother's name
are you sure are you sure
now that i see a pseudonym too funny
clarence w says please say crowder is
coming on the show
ooh well with with the new studio
we will be um we're getting someone to
come out and
change some things we have a very strict
in-studio policy for a lot of reasons
but we may actually
do like maybe like once per month we'll
open up for virtual
because there are people like hassan
[ __ ] who was willing to come on if we
did a virtual thing
and uh potentially people like steven
crowder if we do virtual because
these are both people who host their own
shows hassan
does his live stream and twitch why
would he stop doing his job just to come
and come on here and have a debate or
discussion does it make sense
well but there are some people who are
willing to do it and i think maybe we'll
open up like
maybe like one a month we'll be willing
to do virtual the problem is right now
we don't actually have monitors for
anybody but me
so no one would be able to hear or see
any person on skype we just
we were never set up for because we
never wanted to do it but uh we'll see
we'll see what happens sean
casey fpv says all of this media
censorship feels a lot like man in the
high castle
thank you ivory for exposing a forbidden
glimpse of reality
excellent wow yeah you're welcome my
pleasure
bobby digital says resist the usage of
the word worker it marginalizes everyone
you know we've reached a disgusting
place in our society when you hear
nurses doctors and surgeons referred to
as hospital workers
that's just a group i mean they all work
there
jay dubsky says i just became a member
at timcast.com have you considered
making a youtube channel that mostly
just links to member content and news at
timcast.com
not easy to do um really not easy to do
so
um we have a proprietary service for the
members only thing but the the new
site's coming
and it's gonna be really awesome the
member's only content is gonna have a
preview function which means
if you're not a member you'll get to
watch everyone get to watch the first
minute or so of every video
because maybe you don't want to you know
you're like hey i need a trailer for
this why should i
you know invest in this membership
teaser but i i think it's much easier to
say
if you think that cnn does a great job
and that they should make more money
than us and have more views than us
don't become a member if you think the
inverse and they don't deserve the money
they get or being propped up by youtube
and you want to see us do more work then
please share
these shows and become a member it's all
we can ask for i wonder how much they're
making these days
cnn makes a lot of money yeah but they
spend a lot of money
so you know they had to cut their
airport service they couldn't pay the
airports anymore to keep
to keep it in there well i think i yes
they they they canceled they were paying
airports like was like seven million
dollars a a year or something i forget
how much but yeah they had to pay to
keep cnn i wonder
how much of their ratings was bought
involuntary watchers but then they would
go to these advertisers and be like we
get a million views
look at this and it's like yeah it's
airport and hotels dude
creepy lazarus rec says ufos are real
and we need more money for the military
so obama is saying trump's space force
was a great idea
yes that's what i'm hearing
buffalo bill says why do far leftists
look ill physically and mentally and
conservative women are fine
blonde hair legs but the left all look
like unhealthy
i mean really there could be a
correlation there um
i'm not going to get into it i'm not
going to name the youtuber this youtuber
friend of mine who asked me a question
about this because
we are both noting that when you go to
the rnc though men are all tall
and thin not all every single man but
they're chiseled tend to be chiseled and
tall and the women tend to be like
attractive and slim
and then you go to the dnc though in our
frumpy and the men are short
and i was like what is that and i said i
think it's actually fairly simple
attractive people have they go through
life and people want to do things for
them
you know they're attractive so if you're
an attractive guy then people are trying
to
fawn over you women are you know giving
you things or or constantly talking to
you
if you're ugly it's harder so people who
are uglier
have less attractive privilege they form
collectives
to protect themselves to advocate for
their interests whereas people who are
attractive who've had
an easier go at life just say why should
i join a a union or a collective i'm
doing great
don't force me to do it so you'll end up
with more personal responsibility and
individualist types who are attractive
and more
ugly frumpy collectivists i talked about
this because there's actually like five
different studies that i've cited in the
past
the young turks got so mad when i
brought it up
that their studies saying democrats do
tend to be less attractive than
republicans
and they were like jim's not attractive
himself he's so ugly who's he to say
this and i was like
dude i'm just reading washington post
man like chill out guys i wasn't
insulting you
literally i was citing the washington
post and then they end up pulling up the
store and like well
it's true but come on and i'm like
i don't i don't why you got to be mean
like i wasn't even being mean to you
guys and it was nando i was like nando
bro i know you why are you taking it
personal yeah what are you doing man
calm down all right all right
scrotes mcgoats says tim you should
really really watch the deep space nine
episode in the pale moonlight
it was the most shocking episode of star
trek i'd ever seen when it came out
and in the 2000s it was almost prophetic
wow that's an endorsement i've ever seen
one i will definitely
i'm pretty sure i've seen it i've seen
like every episode of the
of the 90s series of next generation
voyager and deep space nine
but i must admit i can remember
basically everything from the next
generation wow do i love that show
deep space nine i watched every episode
at least
once and some twice and voyager a lot of
the episodes are kind of like half dozed
off for and wasn't really paying
attention so
that's that's the my ranking of how much
i liked it i thought janeway was good
though did you think enterprise was good
i didn't watch it that was the 2000s
yeah that was dracula
i i saw some episodes i wasn't a fan
yeah it was the worst star trek intro
i've ever seen
what was what was that the intro yeah
the next generation is fantastic
the iconic introduction shakespearean
actors of all time
i know right good move i thought january
was all right um but you know
it was whatever i'll check it out though
all right let's see let's uh we'll jump
down and see what we got here
i think i read that one here we go
nerdiest maximus says ian breaks the
laws of physics he goes from genius to
ridiculous faster than the speed of
light
dns records are already decentralized
but you should use a secure dns server
okay there you go thank you good to know
a lot of people telling us to look up
yuri basmanov we get that oh yeah
should we interesting matthew holloway
says tim who do i contact about becoming
a contributing writer
i wrote for the blaze back in 16 and i'd
love to help out from phoenix
shout out the hollow net on mojo 5.0
radio please
there you go um i suppose for now jobs
at timcast.com
but it's very difficult because we are
getting overwhelmed with requests
so definitely appreciate it
josh england says tim youtube has never
allowed me to enable notifications for
irl
it says the action is disabled for
content for kids
well we're certainly not content for
kids that's for sure yeah maybe you have
a setting on your account that
limits you to only be able to watch kid
content or something
right yeah could be
chandylans says how long till the msm
does a reverse project veritas and
places people in the opposition's base
of operations
maybe that's what ivory's doing coming
from
mainstream media are you a double agent
are you a triple agent
a triple agent yeah sure
it's a double agent how does that work
the licensed guru says ivory thank you
for speaking truth you've answered the
prayers of millions
no that means a lot be says
youtube stop your anti-asian hate give
me tim pool notifications the bell does
nothing
that's right it's racism yeah youtube's
racist because you know
i didn't you're part asian yeah i didn't
know that yeah oh really it's a
minority-owned company and youtube is
racist
i'm polish i'm a person of color
officially so people are people of color
watch out youtube
no did you know that yeah i'm one i'm
132nd cherokee
there you go oh really you look like
perfect well then there you go
actually isn't there like a legal
threshold or is that is that yeah i
think it's eight percent so i didn't
make the cut but my grandpa did or i
mean
one eighth one eighth is the is the
cutoff a group called the coalition for
communities of color says that slavic
people
are people of color blonde blonde hair
blue-eyed luke is a person of color
i could see it that was recent wasn't
that like yeah
that was when it was here like in
january blonde is a color i'm glad they
acknowledged that finally geez
mark roberts says i wanted to send 20
bucks but future inflation maybe made me
pay a hundred dollars
thanks for your content please continue
to keep us informed i will do my best
thank you
goblin han says offer her a job you fool
while you still can before somebody
steals her she's a treasure
don't do my mistake from last year
debating myself if i should buy crypto
or no oh
it's like just all of them wow he
compared me to kryptos
he's saying you're going to accrue in
value very quickly
and you're a good store of value
[Laughter]
chad conego says you should glass all of
your extra eggs to preserve them
can keep them good for several months to
a year wait what yeah i look that up
natural eggs out of the chicken but uh
have a coating on it that usually the
ones at the store are rubbed off and
they could last for
a long long what does it mean to glasses
wow that's incredible
yeah glass them water glassing eggs long
term i'll send this to you
cool yeah it sounds great kyle sheridan
says thanks for you and your team's hard
work i would second the recommendation
for guns and gadgets as well as
recommend warrior poet society oh yeah
they both share your love for our
country and direction to fight the
culture war
there you go everybody recommends
warrior poets to me oh yes here's a good
one
william j says you should have carrie
lake on award-winning fox
news 10 anchor from phoenix over 20
years resigned from huge contracts due
to leftist agenda being pushed
now running for ac governor in 2022 i
have seen
her her video talking about this she is
guys
she uh project veritas yeah they
they are friends with her i did not
i i didn't know who she was or that she
existed until
monday right before i did
my thing on the live news
project veritas said by the way there's
this woman who abruptly quit from from
fox in phoenix so
she's from the same company as me cool
that's f
fox corp and this thing these edicts
coming down from new york i still have
to compare notes with her i want to call
her and be like
okay what what what are they doing with
you but uh
she sent she sent project a vera a
veritas
a text message to read to me right
before i went
live which was a nerve-wracking thing to
do and it was such a
sweet encouraging text so i i want to
thank her and i'm meaning to call her
and uh compare notes connect the dots on
what the heck's going on
all right we'll do one more giuseppe
castellino says metal gear solid two
play it or watch the last part of it
with the ai conversation
it's yourself predicted everything to a
t since 0-1
i've heard that the metal gear story is
like prophetic
super cool my friends if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel hit the notification
bell which apparently does nothing at
this point but uh
maybe you can tell your your at-home
digital assistant to set reminders
monday through friday at 8 pm when we do
this show live
and you can follow us on facebook and
instagram tim cast irl you can share our
videos there you go facebook click that
little share button
because we're trying to leverage these
networks to drive more people to
timcast.com
we're going to start producing legit
news we're going to be leveraging these
big networks but we are also on other
networks as well
it's it's it's a difficult battle but
this is part of the exodus where we want
to drive people to an independent
website
your membership at timecast.com is
helping fund independent journalism
so make sure you go to timcast.com for
the bonus segment that is coming up at
around 11 or so
you can follow me personally at tim cast
i've read you want to shout out your
social media channels or anything else
oh sure yeah uh
instagram ivory it's uh real.ivory
at real.ivery on instagram facebook.com
ivoryhecker on twitter it is at
ivoryhecker
i have a telegram um it is linked in the
bio of my instagram
i don't know i think it's so important
right now to diversify your
social media uh this is yeah
these social media corporations are not
about the
free sharing of info so telegram i would
love
if you go to my telegram because uh i'm
not
hearing that they're censoring like the
other ones are
right on i love telegram i'm on we are
change on there but if you want to find
out why msnbc called me a right-wing
racist fox news called me a jihad loving
liberal
you can on look uncensored.com sign up
right now for all the exciting things
that i have going on and of course i
also do videos almost daily
on the youtube channel we are changed
thanks for having me or you can follow
me in crossland.net and ian crossland
across all social media thanks for
coming guys i really
appreciate it i really love you and you
guys can follow me at sourpatchlids on
twitter contrary to all of your comments
in the chat i'm not actually stoned i'm
just
tired as i usually am girl me too i know
the same it's a struggle but yeah my
friends
many super chats saying tim hire this
woman well if you want to find out if
there is a job offer go to timcast.com
become a member and check out the bonus
segments
where uh you'll you'll find out i
suppose so thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all then
bye guys
you